big American Idol news Katy Perry is
officially in as a judge after she had a
little fun with Ellen
so Idol is coming back and supposedly
you're gonna be the first announcement
that you're gonna be a judge on the new
American Idol judge not lest we be judge
but they didn't say anything about
constructive criticism and I'm good at
that so you're gonna be the judge on
American Idol Katy confirmed her spot at
the judge's table this afternoon on
social media she promised quote I'm
bringing it back to the music
[Music]
yesterday Perry was in LA shooting a
carpool karaoke segment with James
Corden she's one of the biggest stars on
the planet The Late Late Show host told
nichelle it's for a prime-time special
next Monday it's gonna be great I'm so
excited
Katie's new Idol job is just the latest
move in what's shaping up to be an epic
battle between the boys and American
Idol yesterday Jennifer Hudson a former
Idol contestant who was just named a
coach on NBC's The Voice performed at
the network's annual presentation for
journalist I want a voice that makes me
want to hit my button and turn my chair
around Hudson says she's in it to win it
this fall it's almost like a game you
got a strategize that okay what Blake
wrote it all right wait what I'm doing
okay now what I'm a gold
[Music]